also ich stehe jetzt hier direkt am
connewitzer kreuz wir haben gerade im
hintergrund eine veranstaltung des links
nicht die heute den zwanzigsten
geburtstag feiern das ist ein
linkspolitiker blog diese veranstaltung
hat zu 100 bis 150 mit teilnehmer
zeitgleich findet noch eine andere
veranstaltung gegen gentrifizierung
statt
die wird dann vermutlich in naher
zukunft mit der anderen gruppe hier
zusammengelegt und da wird dann die
demonstration stattfinden
wie würdest du das polizeiaufgebot
einschätze ist die polizei vorbereitet
auch für eventuelle ausschreitungen wie
wir sie letzte nacht erlebt haben ja
also die polizei ist natürlich ganz
anders vorbereitet als ich es gestern
und vorgestern waren gestern und
vorgestern die veranstaltung man nicht
angemeldet deswegen war die
kommunikation im vornherein mit der
polizei sehr schwierig jetzt haben wir
die situation die veranstaltung ist
angemeldet
dadurch konnte die polizei natürlich
auch die kommunikation aufrechterhalten
die polizei hat aber auch ein großes
aufgebot heute ist die polizei leipzig
unterstützt von der polizei aus
thüringen der bundespolizei und die
polizei hält sich offen
im streitfall tatsächlich dann
wasserwerfer einsetzen zu können
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren